I think when someone dies, when you're grieving, there are things that you expect to feel. But sometimes grief can come out sideways, take strange forms.
我认为当有人去世、当你处于悲伤中时，有些感受是你预料之中的。但有时悲伤会以意想不到的方式显现，呈现出奇怪的形式。
I remember, I think the day my son died or the day after, I hit myself in the face. I don't know why I did it, but I gave myself a bloody nose. And there was a hospice worker there who'd been helping our family. And she said to my mom-- she was like, oh, yeah, that's normal. Don't worry about that.
我记得，我想是在我儿子去世的那天或是第二天，我打了自己的脸。我不知道我为什么要那样做，但我把自己打出了鼻血。当时有一位一直协助我们家庭的临终关怀护士在场。她对我妈妈说——她说，哦，是的，那是正常的。别担心这个。
Oh, we see that all the time.
哦，我们经常见到这种情况。
Yeah. [LAUGHS] I couldn't believe that my baby had died. And I just punched myself, yeah, in the nose.
是的。（笑）我无法相信我的孩子已经去世了。所以我确实打了自己的鼻子，是的。
This is Rob Delaney. His son Henry was about to turn three when he died from a brain tumor. And Rob says the grief that he felt was physical, like physical pain and fatigue and confusion. He forgot the PIN for his bank card, didn't recognize a guy who he worked with all the time. And he's talked about this publicly. He's a comedian and an actor. He's currently on a TV show that he co-created called Catastrophe. And he talks about his son's death when he's asked, hoping that it might be useful or comforting in some small way to other parents going through this.
这是罗伯·德莱尼。他的儿子亨利在快满三岁时因脑瘤去世。罗伯说，他所感受到的悲伤是生理性的，就像身体的疼痛、疲劳和困惑。他忘记了银行卡的密码，认不出经常一起工作的同事。他公开谈论过这些。他是一位喜剧演员和演员，目前正在出演一部他参与创作的电视剧《大祸临头》。当被问及儿子的去世时，他会谈论这件事，希望能以某种方式给其他经历此事的父母带来一点帮助或安慰。
And it's interesting when he discusses his son's death. In public, he is pretty even-keeled, except when he gets on the subject of how people in his life reacted to Henry's death, how it was hard for some people to acknowledge what had happened. Here he is on a British talk show.
有趣的是，当他谈论儿子的死时，在公开场合，他表现得相当冷静，除非谈到他生活中的人对亨利去世的反应，以及有些人难以承认所发生的事情。以下是他在一个英国谈话节目中的片段。
So my wife was pregnant, for example, when Henry died, OK? And there were some people who would find out about that. And I have never seen such relief on people's faces. They'd be like, oh, so another big thing-- so I don't have to talk about his dead baby. I can talk about his new shiny baby that's coming. And I wanted to kill those people because, I mean, that's not news. It's great, but we all know pregnant people. Big whoop, you know? People get pregnant. But my fucking two-year-old, a little bit before his third birthday, he died in my home on my couch.
例如，亨利去世时，我的妻子正怀着孕，对吧？有些人发现了这一点。我从来没见过人们脸上露出过那种如释重负的表情。他们好像在说，哦，太好了，又一件大事——这样我就不必谈论他死掉的宝宝了。我可以谈论他即将到来的新宝宝。我当时想杀了那些人，因为，我的意思是，那又不是什么大新闻。这很好，但我们都认识怀孕的人。那又怎样，你知道吗？人们都会怀孕。但我那该死的两岁大的孩子，在他三岁生日前一点点的时候，在我家里的沙发上去世了。
When Rob was nice enough to come into the studio to talk to me about all this. He told me he gets it. Seeing somebody in pain makes lots of people uncomfortable. They don't know what to say. They sidestep. They avoid.
当罗伯大方地来到演播室和我谈论这一切时，他告诉我他理解。看到别人痛苦会让很多人感到不自在。他们不知道该说什么。他们回避，他们躲闪。
I'm sure in my own life, I used to do it in the past, too. But if you'd like me to, quote, "get over" not the death of my child, but, say, this wave of emotions that are making you uncomfortable, then the best thing to do would be to let them happen and let me feel them, and then they'll sort of dissipate organically. And then we can carry on with whatever idiotic thing you want to do, you moron insensitive person. The least another person can do in the human family is to bear an ounce of my shipping container ship of pain by accepting that I'm upset, sad, angry, confused.
我相信在我自己的生活中，我过去也曾这样做过。但如果你希望我“克服”的不是我孩子的死亡，而是那一波让你感到不舒服的情绪，那么最好的办法就是让它们发生，让我感受它们，然后它们就会自然地消散。然后我们就可以继续做你想做的任何蠢事了，你这个迟钝的混蛋。作为人类大家庭的一员，另一个人能做的最起码的事，就是通过接受我的心烦、悲伤、愤怒和困惑，来分担我那如货轮般沉重的痛苦。
Some people just have a hard time acknowledging death. And that's true when they hear about somebody else's losses, and it's true when it's their loss to face. When somebody close to them dies, they look away, avoid grieving, throw themselves into work, into drinking, distract themselves with TV, get stuck ruminating over feelings of guilt or shame that they could have done more for the person who died. It's common to do that, and it's more common if your loss was bigger.
有些人就是很难承认死亡。当他们听到别人的损失时是这样，当他们自己面对损失时也是这样。当与他们亲近的人去世时，他们会移开目光，回避悲伤，全身心投入到工作中，借酒浇愁，用电视来分散注意力，沉溺于本可以为死者做得更多这类负罪感或羞耻感中。这样做很常见，如果你的损失更大，那就更常见了。
And one of the reasons that I was so interested to talk to Rob Delaney is that when his two-year-old died, Henry, he did not do any of those things. He did not look away from the pain. I think one reason that he was sort of inclined or able to do it this way is that he's sober, has been for a long time. This is something he's talked about in his standup. He told me that when Henry died, some of the skills that he learned from years of sobriety -- where you try to face what is real as unflinchingly as possible -- those skills turned out to be very helpful.
我之所以如此有兴趣与罗伯·德莱尼交谈，原因之一是，当他两岁的儿子亨利去世时，他并没有做任何那些事。他没有回避痛苦。我认为他之所以倾向于或能够以这种方式面对，原因之一是他戒酒了，而且已经很久了。这是他在脱口秀中谈论过的事情。他告诉我，当亨利去世时，他从多年戒酒中学到的一些技能——即尽量不退缩地面对真实——被证明非常有帮助。
So that when the incredibly intense storms of sadness and anger and confusion would come up, I didn't try to manage them or push them away, but rather to let them move through me as they needed to do.
所以，当极其强烈的悲伤、愤怒和困惑的风暴袭来时，我没有试图去控制它们或推开它们，而是让它们按其需要穿过我的身体。
Knowing that you just have to go through it.
知道你必须经历它。
Yeah.
是的。
I think it's really important to acknowledge it's going to be a real nightmare for a good long while. And you're going to cry, and you'll probably puke sometimes. And I know that's not "the sun will come out and everything's going to be fine." I really try to not do that because there's going to be enough people that are going to blow smoke up your butt and waste your time. And I don't understand that approach. So I do try to be kind of brutal when I talk about it. And I feel like the worse of a picture I can paint, then the better friend I've been to you.
我认为承认这将是一段长期的噩梦非常重要。你会哭，有时可能会呕吐。我知道这并不是“太阳总会升起，一切都会好起来”那种话。我真的尽量不那样说，因为总会有足够多的人对你灌输迷魂汤，浪费你的时间。我不理解那种方式。所以我谈论它时确实会尽量残酷一点。我觉得我描述的景象越糟糕，我作为一个朋友就越称职。
It's This American Life, by the way, from WBEZ Chicago. I'm Ira Glass. Today's radio show is going to be about people figuring out how to grieve, most of them kind of inventing it for themselves and mostly doing a decent job of it. We got interested in this because we're at this moment right now where so many people are grieving. COVID deaths are nearing 600,000 here in the United States. The worldwide number is officially 3.5 million, but it might be twice as many as that.
顺便说一句，这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的广播节目是关于人们如何学习应对悲伤的，大多数人是在为自己摸索，而且做得相当不错。我们对这个话题感兴趣，是因为我们正处于一个有许多人正在经历悲伤的时刻。在美国，新冠死亡人数接近60万。全世界的数字官方是350万，但实际数字可能是这个的两倍。
So what helps in these situations for people experiencing the most traumatic kinds of grief? In Rob Delaney's case, it's now been three years since his son died. And I talked to him about what he has learned over that time about what works and about what helped him.
那么，在这些情况下，对于经历最痛苦悲伤的人来说，什么是有帮助的？在罗伯·德莱尼的例子中，他儿子去世已经三年了。我和他聊了聊这段时间他学到的有效方法，以及什么对他有帮助。
Yeah, the most helpful thing for me has been other bereaved parents. Because when you come together, more useful than any of the words that anyone said to me would be if I saw a parent whose child had been dead longer than mine had, and I saw that they were able to tie their shoes. Was their shirt tucked in? Basic functions-- just watching them pick grapes off of a stem and eat them. And I thought if they can do that, then I'll be able to do that one day, hopefully.
是的，对我来说最有用的是其他失去孩子的父母。因为当你聚在一起时，比任何人对我说的任何话都更有用的是，我看到一位孩子去世时间比我的孩子更久的父母，看到他们能够系好鞋带。他们的衬衫塞进去了吗？基本的功能——仅仅是看着他们从茎上摘下葡萄吃掉。我想如果他们能做到，那我有一天也能做到，希望如此。
Also, he says, in those groups with parents whose kids have died, they can say things out loud with each other that they can't say to most other people.
他还说，在那些失去孩子的父母团体中，他们可以互相说出一些在大多数其他人面前说不出来的话。
It was kind of funny, because things are said and happened in those meetings that would scorch the eyeballs of your average person who hasn't had an experience like that. I mean, I'm not going to generally talk about the physical circumstances of Henry's death and his body after he died. But with other bereaved parents, we can talk about that unbelievably precious time that you spend with your dead child's body. But if you were with your child when they died, caring for and attending to the body of your child after their life has left them-- are some very beautiful and loving conversations that we've had there that I couldn't have anywhere else, but that are very precious to me and to them.
这有点好笑，因为在那些聚会中说出和发生的事情，会让那些没有经历过这类事情的普通人感到震惊。我的意思是，我通常不会谈论亨利去世时的身体状况，也不会谈论他去世后的身体。但与其他失去孩子的父母在一起，我们可以谈论那段陪伴已故孩子身体的令人难以置信的宝贵时光。但如果你在孩子去世时陪伴在他们身边，在他们生命消逝后照料和关注他们的身体——我们确实在那里进行了一些非常美丽和充满爱的对话，我在其他任何地方都无法进行这些对话，但这对我和他们来说都非常宝贵。
Why do you-- why do you think it's so important to talk about that moment after your child dies, and you're there with your child's body?
你为什么——你为什么认为谈论孩子去世后、你陪伴在孩子遗体旁的那个时刻如此重要？
I mean, I guess it's like being to the moon of a distant planet. It's somewhere you never think you would go. So to be able to talk through that with another person is helpful.
我的意思是，我想这就像去了一个遥远行星的月球。那是你从未想过自己会去的地方。所以能和另一个人谈论这一点很有帮助。
It reminds me of this thing that, when they treat trauma, one of the steps, one of the most important things is to go back to the moment that the person was traumatized and have the person talk it through and examine it and get their head around it.
这让我想起一件事，在治疗创伤时，步骤之一，最重要的事情之一，就是回到那个人受到创伤的时刻，让那个人谈论它、检查它并理清它。
Yeah, I believe that, because I repeat to myself the story of my son's death in very simple terms of his illness and death. And I say them out loud to myself when I'm walking around, walking down the street. My baby boy got sick. We took a while trying to figure out what it was, went to a lot of doctors. They found out what it was. It was very bad. It got worse and worse. And then he died. And he's dead. I can't even believe what I just said, you know?
是的，我相信这一点，因为我用非常简单的语言向自己重复我儿子生病和去世的故事。当我四处走动、走在街上时，我会大声对自己说。我的小宝贝生病了。我们花了些时间试图弄清楚那是什么病，看了很多医生。他们查出来了。病情非常严重。它变得越来越糟。然后他去世了。他死了。我甚至不敢相信我刚才说了什么，你知道吗？
I know talking to you, the thing that I didn't understand before we started talking is just like, oh, you have to keep looking at it because it doesn't seem real. It's just hard to believe it's real.
我知道和你交谈，我之前不理解的一点就是，哦，你必须一直注视着它，因为它看起来并不真实。只是很难相信这是真的。
Yeah. I mean, for me, it's as unreal as if the Martians landed on my front lawn.
是的。我的意思是，对我来说，这就像火星人降落在我的前草坪上一样不真实。
Rob says that, three years in, he knows he's doing better, though he said that he hasn't figured out how to talk about that publicly yet. Because he thinks the message "you'll get better" is pushed way too much, and the message "this is going to suck, and you're going have to live through that" is not pushednearly enough. He told me the waves of grief do still come, but they're less often. And Henry's still on his mind a lot. In fact, he told me he thinks about Henry as much now as he thinks about his three other children, like equal to the other children, so a fourth of that time. And he likes it that way. It still hurts, he says. But he wouldn't have it any other way.
罗伯说，三年过去了，他知道自己正在好转，尽管他说他还没弄清楚如何公开谈论这一点。因为他认为“你会好起来的”这种信息被推得太多了，而“这会很难受，你必须经历这一切”的信息却被推得远远不够。他告诉我，悲伤的浪潮确实还会袭来，但频率降低了。亨利依然经常出现在他脑海中。事实上，他告诉我，他现在想亨利的时间和他想另外三个孩子的时间一样多，和其他孩子相等，所以占他总时间的四分之一。他喜欢这样。他说，这仍然很痛。但他不会改变任何一点。
Act One, Goodbye, Mr. Facey. So a couple of months ago, the transit authority in New York City, the MTA, created a memorial for its workers who died from COVID. The memorial is a video. It's simple. Picture after picture of each person, bus drivers, train conductors, cleaners, their faces in black and white. Behind them, a solid color background. This, what you're hearing now, is the music that plays as they go by. And there's a poem, which appears in seven of the languages spoken on the trains and buses of New York City. The video got passed around on YouTube and ran on video screens in some subway stations.
第一幕，再见，法西先生。所以几个月前，纽约市交通管理局（MTA）为因新冠去世的员工设立了一个纪念碑。这个纪念碑是一个视频。很简单。一张接一张的照片，每个人，公交车司机、列车员、清洁工，他们的脸是黑白的。在他们身后，是一个纯色的背景。你现在听到的就是他们经过时播放的音乐。还有一首诗，它以纽约市地铁和公交车上所说的七种语言呈现。这段视频在YouTube上流传，并在一些地铁站的视频屏幕上播放。
The MTA lost more employees than any agency in New York City. As of today, 164 people. 164 have disappeared from train lines and maintenance shops and break rooms. One of our producers, Chana Joffe-Walt, wondered what it was like for surviving transit workers to watch a memorial like this for the co-workers, people who died doing a job they're still doing. Here's Chana.
MTA失去的员工比纽约市任何机构都要多。截至今天，共有164人。164人从铁路线、维修车间和休息室中消失了。我们的一位制片人查娜·乔夫-沃尔特想知道，幸存的交通员工看着这样一段纪念他们去世同事的视频是什么感觉，这些人死于他们至今仍在从事的工作。下面是查娜的报道。
I talked to a lot of transit workers. They had a lot of different feelings about this memorial. They felt recognized. They felt angry. They felt exhausted. They felt lucky to have survived. Some wanted to watch it over and over. Some wanted all of us to watch it over and over. Some couldn't bring themselves to watch it at all. One station agent told me she believed it should be in the Metropolitan Museum of Art.
我和许多交通员工谈过。他们对这个纪念碑有许多不同的感受。他们感到被认可。他们感到愤怒。他们感到精疲力竭。他们感到幸存下来很幸运。有些人想一遍又一遍地看。有些人希望我们所有人都能一遍又一遍地看。有些人根本无法让自己去观看。一位车站工作人员告诉我，她认为这应该放在大都会艺术博物馆里。
For the purposes of this show, though, about grief, I want to introduce you to just one person I talked to about the memorial-- Francis Lai-Fang. Francis stood apart in his reaction to the video. His boss and mentor died of COVID, and he's in there. And the whole time we talked, Francis seemed to be in the middle of a feeling that he was trying to work his way through. I met him at a shop. He works in hydraulics for the MTA. He's 52 years old, a manager. He told me there's an office upstairs where we could talk, but it took us 40 minutes to get there, as Francis eagerly pointed to every fan, pump, and truck along the way.
不过，为了本期关于悲伤的节目，我想向大家介绍我采访过的关于这个纪念碑的唯一一个人——弗朗西斯·莱-方。弗朗西斯对这段视频的反应显得与众不同。他的老板和导师死于新冠，他就在视频里。在整个交谈过程中，弗朗西斯似乎处于一种他正试图理清的感觉之中。我在一个车间见到了他。他在MTA的液压部门工作。他今年52岁，是一名经理。他告诉我楼上有个办公室我们可以谈谈，但我们花了40分钟才到那里，因为弗朗西斯一路上热心地指着每一个风扇、泵和卡车。
What we have on this truck is going to be pumps to pump water out of any situation that we might encounter.
这辆卡车上装的是泵，用于在任何我们可能遇到的情况下抽水。
When there's an emergency, when water covers the subway tracks or snow blocks the stairs or platforms, the people in hydraulics jump in these trucks, race across the city, and clear the way. Francis is a man who manages, somehow, after decades, to still be enamored with the objects of his daily work.
当发生紧急情况时，当水淹没地铁轨道或雪堵住楼梯或站台时，液压部门的人就会跳上这些卡车，穿过城市，清理道路。弗朗西斯是一个在几十年后依然对自己日常工作的物件着迷的管理者。
And once that sucker starts running, 1,500 gallons a minute.
一旦那个大家伙开始运转，每分钟能抽1500加仑。
COVID arrived here at the hydraulic shop in March 2020. One of Francis' workers came in coughing. The next day, Francis was coughing. Day after, he was in quarantine and getting calls from all of his co-workers-- all sick.
2020年3月，新冠到达了这里的液压车间。弗朗西斯的一名工人咳嗽着走进来。第二天，弗朗西斯就开始咳嗽。之后的一天，他被隔离，并接到了所有同事的电话——所有人都病了。
I was scared for them because you could hear it in their voice, you know? And I would call every morning. And I'm like, yo. Once they answered, I felt good. Once the phone was answered, I felt good. But if you didn't answer, my heart was starting to worry. Because it was just, you didn't know because people was dropping like flies.
我为他们感到害怕，因为你可以从他们的声音里听出来，你知道吗？我每天早上都会打电话。我就说，喂。一旦他们接听，我就感觉很好。一旦电话接通，我就感觉很好。但如果你不接，我的心就开始担心。因为你根本不知道，因为人们就像苍蝇一样接连倒下。
Then, Francis got another call.
然后，弗朗西斯接到了另一个电话。
He said, yo, you heard about Facey? And I was like, please don't tell me. Please don't say it. No, no, no. And I just kept saying, no, no, no, no, no. And that's all I could say, was no, no, no.
他说，喂，你听说法西的事了吗？我当时就说，求你别告诉我。求你别说。不，不，不。我一直重复着说，不，不，不，不，不。那就是我能说的全部，就是不，不，不。
Clarence Facey, a 58-year-old superintendent from Guyana who cleared the vast subway system after numerous floods over numerous decades, had died. He was nine months away from retirement. Francis met Clarence Facey three decades ago when they started in hydraulics. Francis was 19 years old. Clarence Facey wasn't that much older, but Francis looked up to him from the beginning, called him Mr. Facey. He studied the way Mr. Facey focused, the way he talked. And in particular, Francis admired the way Mr. Facey could always keep his cool, even when he was disrespected.
克拉伦斯·法西，一位来自圭亚那的58岁主管，他在几十年的时间里清理了无数次洪水后的庞大地铁系统，他去世了。离他退休还有九个月。弗朗西斯三十年前刚进液压部门时遇到了克拉伦斯·法西。弗朗西斯当时19岁。克拉伦斯·法西并没有比他大多少，但弗朗西斯从一开始就敬仰他，称他为法西先生。他研究法西先生专注的样子，他说话的方式。特别是，弗朗西斯钦佩法西先生即使在受到不尊重时也能保持冷静的方式。
You could see that he's seconds away of just losing it, but he always had that way of just-- always liked to keep things nice and smooth and calm. He was the coolest cat. I will go crazy over stuff. He'd-- calm down. Don't take it personal. He always said, listen, man, it's just a job. We're going to be here, and then we're going to be gone.
你可以看出他离爆发只有几秒钟的时间了，但他总是有那种方式——总是喜欢让事情保持得愉快、顺利和平静。他是最酷的人。我会为琐事抓狂。他会说——冷静点。别往心里去。他总是说，听着，伙计，这只是份工作。我们现在会在这里，然后我们就会离开。
They were mostly work friends. But sometimes they'd go out with other West Indian guys from the shop. Francis is from Trinidad. And for years, after their shift, Mr. Facey would give Francis a ride to the train station. They'd chat about the property Facey owned in Guyana and how he planned to go back when he retired.
他们主要是工作上的朋友。但有时他们会和其他来自车间的西印度群岛人一起出去。弗朗西斯来自特立尼达。多年来，下班后，法西先生会载弗朗西斯一程去火车站。他们会聊聊法西在圭亚那拥有的房产，以及他计划退休后如何回国。
The memorial the MTA made, it serves partly as a marker, a way to say, here are our losses. It is now time to grieve them. And Francis feels that. Yeah, it's been a year. It does feel like it's time to grieve. But it hasn't come for him yet. He says it just never felt real. From right after Clarence Facey passed in early April.
MTA制作的纪念碑，在一定程度上起到了标记的作用，是一种说出“这是我们的损失，现在是哀悼他们的时候了”的方式。弗朗西斯感到了这一点。是的，已经一年了。确实感觉是时候哀悼了。但这种感觉还没有降临到他身上。他说他从四月初克拉伦斯·法西去世后，就一直觉得这一切不真实。
They had a service, right? But I couldn't go. I was quarantined.
他们举行了仪式，对吧？但我没能去。我被隔离了。
Do you think it would feel more real to you had you been able to go to the service?
你认为如果你能参加那个仪式，你会觉得更真实吗？
I know who I am in funerals. I definitely would have cried. There's always that one point where I just can't hold it anymore. And I break down, and I cry. And I know how West Indians are. They always sing this one song. Oh my gosh, it kills me. It just brings the tears, but I still-- I still haven't shed a tear yet. I've been close, and I was close. But I still haven't shed a tear. And it's going on a year and change. And I know I will. It's going to come one day. It's going to come.
我知道我在葬礼上是什么样的人。我肯定会哭。总有那么一个时刻我再也忍受不了了。我会崩溃，我会哭泣。我知道西印度群岛人是什么样的。他们总是唱这一首歌。哦天哪，这杀了我。它只会带来眼泪，但我仍然——我仍然没有流过一滴眼泪。我曾接近过，我确实接近过。但我仍然没流过一滴泪。这已经过了一年多了。我知道我会的。总有一天会来的。总会来的。
For the rest of our time together, Francis keeps circling back to this, the fact that he has not yet cried. This is not something I asked about. But he seems to be actively trying to figure it out. Why hasn't it happened? He couldn't go to a funeral in person, so he did not cry. Then there was the memorial online a few weeks later.
在我们剩下的共处时间里，弗朗西斯一直在绕回这一点，他还没有哭过的事实。这不是我问的问题。但他似乎在积极地试图弄清楚原因。为什么没发生？他没能亲自参加葬礼，所以他没哭。然后几周后有在线纪念仪式。
They had a service for him, but it was on Teams, like a video. And they show him. And I couldn't believe it, but I still didn't cry. But I know me. I'm telling you, it's going to happen.
他们为他举行了仪式，但是在Teams上，就像一个视频。他们展示了他。我简直不敢相信，但我还是没哭。但我了解我自己。我告诉你，这一定会发生的。
I asked Francis, did he want to cry? Did he wish he could? He said no. It's just weird. It's weird that I didn't. Not after he died, after the services, even after I got out of quarantine and came back to work.
我问弗朗西斯，他想哭吗？他希望自己能哭吗？他说没有。这只是很奇怪。很奇怪我没哭。在他去世后，在仪式结束后，甚至在我结束隔离回到工作岗位后都没有。
It was weird. It was very hollow. I'd come upstairs. They had a bunch of pictures on the door. So that was tough, just seeing--
这很奇怪。非常空虚。我来到楼上。门上有一堆照片。所以那很艰难，仅仅是看着——
What do you mean pictures on the wall?
墙上的照片是什么意思？
They would have memory pictures of him from different times. People had pictures from when he was younger, when he first came in. They had the whole doors full of pictures. I still didn't break down. I still didn't cry.
他们会有他不同时期的纪念照片。人们有他年轻时刚进来时的照片。他们整个门上都贴满了照片。我还是没崩溃。我还是没哭。
When he left work at the end of the day and Mr. Facey was not there to give him a ride to the train, he didn't fall apart. All the times he rushed to Mr. Facey's office to tell him something, forgetting he wasn't there anymore. Even on the one year anniversary of Mr. Facey's death, Francis and a bunch of guys went out to his graveside, drank, told stories, left bottles of gin. Still, he says, no tears. I don't know.
当他在一天结束时离开工作场所，法西先生没有在那里载他去火车站时，他没有崩溃。所有那些他冲进法西先生办公室想告诉他什么事，却忘记他已经不在那里的时刻。即使在法西先生去世一周年纪念日，弗朗西斯和一群人也去了他的墓地，喝酒、讲故事、留下几瓶金酒。他说，依然没有眼泪。我不知道。
What is it to grieve someone you've worked with? It's not like Clarence Facey was a close friend of Francis' or family. Every person in that memorial video has loved ones. And then there are dozens, maybe hundreds of other people like Francis, people who sit a few circles out, people who lost the co-worker who they always said hello to on the way to the bathroom, the woman they always chatted with in the break room, the person who was just always there. Clarence Facey had been there for Francis' entire working life. And now he wasn't.
哀悼一个与你共事过的人意味着什么？克拉伦斯·法西并不是弗朗西斯的好朋友或家人。纪念视频中的每个人都有亲人。然后还有几十个，甚至几百个像弗朗西斯这样的人，坐在圈子外围的人，失去了一个在去洗手间路上总是点头打招呼的同事，那个在休息室里总是聊天的女人，那个一直都在那儿的人。克拉伦斯·法西在弗朗西斯整个工作生涯中都在那儿。而现在，他不在了。
When the MTA put out the memorial video, Francis saw it posted online, saw people passing it around. He waited. It wasn't until recently that he sat down and clicked play. He told me he watched each face pass by until he got to Mr. Facey.
当MTA发布纪念视频时，弗朗西斯看到它在网上发布，看到人们转发它。他等待着。直到最近他才坐下来点击播放。他告诉我他看着每张脸经过，直到他看到法西先生。
4:08, at 4 minutes and 8 seconds in.
4:08，在4分8秒的时候。
Wait, you know which minute he is in the memorial video?
等等，你知道他在纪念视频里的第几分钟？
Yes, and when his picture did come up, it had the tears there, man. It's just the tears didn't fall.
是的，当他的照片出现时，眼泪就在那里，伙计。只是眼泪没掉下来。
When we first started talking, I read Francis as someone who was holding back, turning away from grief. But Francis is actively engaged in some small, ongoing grieving process. Repeatedly noting every single time you haven't cried, that is a kind of grief. Not the kind that overwhelms you. It's not falling down on the ground, sobbing grief. It's just an ambient feeling that hovers. It's a grief that just sits there.
当我们刚开始交谈时，我把弗朗西斯看作一个在压抑、回避悲伤的人。但弗朗西斯实际上积极参与了一些微小的、持续的悲伤过程。反复记录下你每次没哭的时刻，那本身就是一种悲伤。不是那种压倒你的悲伤。不是那种倒地痛哭的悲伤。这只是一种徘徊的、弥漫的感觉。这是一种仅仅坐在那里的悲伤。
On our way out of the building, I learned that Francis actually made his own memorial. And it's kind of a tribute to this version of grief. He points it out as we pass by Mr. Facey's office door.
在离开大楼的路上，我了解到弗朗西斯实际上制作了他自己的纪念碑。这算是对这种悲伤版本的一种致敬。当我们经过法西先生办公室门前时，他指了出来。
And I got a plaque for him made up. And I put it outside his door on the wall. But I didn't put it that he passed away. I put it that he retired. His last day when he passed away was his retirement day, and that's what I did. And I--
我为他做了一块牌匾。我把它放在他门外的墙上。但我没有写他去世了。我写的是他退休了。他去世的那天就是他的退休日，这就是我做的。我——
You didn't want to put that he died?
你不想写他去世了？
No, I can't do that. Some people ask me, well, he never retired. And I'm like, I know. But I'm not going to put a plaque of my friend is gone, you know? I'm going to say he's retired. That's how I see him as gone. That's the way I see it. If they decide to take it down, it'll be when I'm gone.
不，我做不到。有些人问我，嗯，他从没退休过。我就说，我知道。但我不会去挂一块关于我朋友离去的牌匾，你知道吗？我要说他退休了。这就是我看待他离去的方式。这就是我看待它的方式。如果他们决定把它摘下来，那只能是在我离开之后。
It's a simple black plaque with gold lettering on the wall. I ask if he'll read it.
这是一块简单的黑色牌匾，墙上有金色的字。我问他是否可以读一下。
Will you read it?
你会读一下吗？
Me?
我？
Yeah.
是的。
No, I can't.
不，我做不到。
No? OK.
不？好的。
He says, "I can't do that." So I will. It reads, "Clarence Facey, hero of the Hydraulics Department, hired August 21, 1989, retired April 4, 2020." It thanks Mr. Facey for believing in them, for guiding through example, and inspiring with passion, for being a mentor, a co-worker, and a gentleman. Quote, "We appreciate your humble leadership. You will always be remembered as a great example. With great honor and respect, from your Hydraulics family."
他说，“我做不到。”所以我来读。上面写着：“克拉伦斯·法西，液压部门英雄，1989年8月21日受聘，2020年4月4日退休。”它感谢法西先生相信他们，以身作则引导他们，用激情激励他们，感谢他作为导师、同事和绅士。“引用：我们感谢您谦逊的领导。您将永远作为伟大的榜样被铭记。怀着极大的荣誉和敬意，来自您的液压家庭。”
That's very beautiful.
这非常美丽。
The closest Francis ever seems to crying is right then, standing by the plaque. But he doesn't. Puts his hands on his face, says, "Oh, boy," and moves along. This is the memorial that works for Francis, the one where Mr. Facey is honored, but does not die, one that acknowledges the grief that sits in this office and still allows him to keep moving.
弗朗西斯看起来最接近哭泣的时刻就是那时，站在牌匾旁。但他还是没哭。把双手捂在脸上，说，“噢，伙计”，然后继续往前走。这是对弗朗西斯奏效的纪念方式，在这种方式里，法西先生受到了尊敬，但他并没有死去，这承认了坐在办公室里的悲伤，同时也让他能够继续前行。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our show.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Two, When It Rains. So there's this concept that people who study grief talk about called cumulative grief. That is, a pile-up of losses that happen either all at once or in quick succession. This is something that one of our producers Sean Cole, unfortunately, became personally familiar with this year. Here he is.
第二幕，当下雨时。关于悲伤，研究者们讨论过一个叫累积悲伤的概念。也就是，一系列损失全部发生，或者是接二连三地发生。这是我们的一位制片人肖恩·科尔不幸在今年亲身体验到的事情。下面是他的自述。
The pile-up of things that happened to me, it was four different events that happened over the course of just a few months. I only saw one of them coming, the first one. My stepfather Ed, who I adored, died of a really aggressive lung cancer on December 31, 2020. You might have heard him on the show before, actually. I talked to him for a couple of different stories. One way in which I was really lucky, I got to spend a lot of time with him in person in his final weeks. In October, right after his diagnosis, I interviewed him at the hospital about the election, which would be his last. At that point, he still wasn't sure how much time he had left. He just knew that it wasn't a lot. But he said that didn't bother him.
发生在我身上的事情，是在短短几个月内发生的四件不同的事。我只预见到了其中一件，也就是第一件。我所崇拜的继父埃德，死于一种非常凶猛的肺癌，时间是2020年12月31日。你可能以前在节目中听到过他，事实上，我就几个不同的故事采访过他。我很幸运的一点是，在他生命的最后几周，我有机会亲自陪伴他很长时间。10月份，在他确诊后不久，我在医院就选举问题采访了他，那也将是他最后一次参与选举。当时，他还不确定自己还剩下多少时间。他只知道不多了。但他表示那并不困扰他。
I think it's an excellent time, in the next two or three years, to die.
我认为未来两三年是去世的绝佳时机。
Why?
为什么？
You're avoiding all sorts of huge problems. We have global warming coming out big time. The country is still going to be divided, even if Biden wins. Europe is going totalitarian. This country is going more totalitarian, which is scary. So there's not much to look forward to. Things I would like to see are answers to big questions. Is there intelligent life in this universe? There's none on Earth.
你可以避免各种巨大的问题。我们有全球变暖即将来临。即使拜登赢了，国家仍将分裂。欧洲正在走向极权主义。这个国家也变得越来越极权，这很可怕。所以没什么值得期待的。我想看到的是对重大问题的回答。这个宇宙中有智慧生命吗？地球上没有。
Six weeks after recording that in early December, I watched him reach for the TV remote, thinking it was a phone. Then he asked me what the remote was for. We learned later that, on top of everything else, he'd had a stroke. It was really then that our grieving began, the kind of pre-grief. He spent the last five days of his life in hospice-- in-home hospice, mercifully. They brought in a hospital bed and set it up in my mom's old bedroom. She died in 2015.
记录那次谈话六周后的12月初，我看着他伸手去拿电视遥控器，以为那是电话。然后他问我遥控器是干什么用的。我们后来才知道，除此之外，他还中风了。也就是从那时起，我们的悲伤开始了，那是一种预悲伤。他在临终关怀中度过了生命的最后五天——幸运的是，是在家中临终关怀。他们带来了一张医院病床，安装在我妈妈以前的卧室里。她在2015年去世了。
My sister Maggie and I co-managed Ed's care, squirting syringefuls of morphine into his mouth, helping the nurse's aides change his diapers. Early that final week, he asked me in this hoarse whisper, "How long before the cancer wipes me out?" "They don't really know," I said. Then I said, "Are you ready to die?" He looked at me. "No man is ready to die," he said. "Do you have any feelings about it?" I asked him. His face kind of softened, thoughtful, like he was checking. "No, not especially," he said. I don't know what I'd been expecting to hear.
我和我妹妹玛吉共同管理了埃德的护理，将注射器里的吗啡推入他的嘴里，帮助护理助理更换他的尿布。在那最后一周的早期，他用沙哑的耳语问我，“癌症还要多久才会夺走我的命？”“他们并不真的知道，”我说。然后我问，“你准备好面对死亡了吗？”他看着我。“没有人准备好面对死亡，”他说。“你对此有什么感受吗？”我问他。他的脸变得柔和，若有所思，好像在检查自己的内心。“不，没什么特别的感受，”他说。我不知道我原本期待听到什么。
His heart finally stopped around 3:30 in the afternoon on New Year's Eve. When the reality sunk in, I bent down, kissed his forehead, and started to cry. I can't explain this, and maybe I don't need to. But it was different when Ed was breathing. Even though he was unconscious, you at least knew he was alive. They say nothing prepares you. I had been living in a house with a rapidly-dying hospice patient for a week. It had gotten to the point where Maggie and I were even wishing for this moment, because what kind of existence is that? And yet, when the moment came, I just wasn't ready. I'm still not ready.
新年前夜下午3点半左右，他的心脏终于停止了跳动。当现实沉入心底，我弯下腰，吻了他的额头，开始哭泣。我无法解释这一点，也许我也不需要解释。但在埃德呼吸的时候感觉是不一样的。尽管他失去了知觉，你至少知道他还活着。人们常说没有什么能让你准备好。我已经在家里和一个迅速凋零的临终关怀病人住了一周。事情已经发展到玛吉和我甚至希望这一刻尽快到来，因为那样的生存状态又算什么呢？然而，当那一刻真的到来时，我就是没准备好。我现在还是没准备好。
After we left the room, I went back in and hugged Ed's dead body one last time. "Ed, you fucking asshole," I said, burying my face in his neck. And then I said, "I love you so much." Then I didn't say anything. Then I said, "This probably isn't sanitary."
离开房间后，我又回去最后一次拥抱了埃德冰冷的遗体。“埃德，你这该死的混蛋，”我埋头在他脖颈处说道。然后我说，“我太爱你了。”接着我什么也没说。然后我说，“这可能不卫生。”
Losing a parent can make you think the biggest thoughts. Like, for instance, this one-- when someone dies, they don't just die. It's like they keep dying in pieces as time wears on, the moment of their demise drifting farther and farther away from you, like a raft heading for the horizon. It happened with my mom. I found I didn't want to leave that early temporal orbit of her death before it became just another thing that happened to me.
失去父母会让你思考最重大的问题。例如，这一个——当有人去世时，他们并不只是死去。就像他们随着时间的推移一点点地继续离去，他们消亡的时刻离你越来越远，就像漂向地平线的木筏。我妈妈去世时就是这样。我发现我不想在那个悲伤的初始阶段离开，直到它变成另一件发生在我身上的平常事。
That said, I didn't face my grief about my mom head on when it happened. I distracted myself, tried to, quote, "get back to normal too quickly" and get drunk and loud at events. I didn't want to make mistakes like that this time. I wanted to take time and really feel the loss, maybe go somewhere and just sit by myself. But I wasn't really able to. Because losing Ed led pretty directly to the second thing I lost-- my relationship with a woman I'll call Melanie.
话虽如此，我妈妈去世时我并没有正面面对我的悲伤。我分散了自己的注意力，试图“过快地恢复正常”，在活动中喝得大醉、吵闹。这一次我不想再犯那样的错误。我想花时间真正感受损失，也许去某个地方独自坐着。但我做不到。因为失去埃德直接导致了我失去的第二件事——我和一个我会称之为梅兰妮的女人的关系。
See, another big thought I had, staring into the portal that Ed had just passed through, took kind of a weird shape. I thought I'm going to be 60 in 10 years. 10 years ago, I turned 40. I remember turning 40. It feels like almost no time has passed. And what did I want to do with the rest of my days here on Earth? There's so much I've been putting off, a long list. And something I knew definitively now was that having kids was nowhere on that list.
看，我盯着埃德刚刚经过的那个门户，脑子里有了另一个巨大的想法，形状有点怪。10年后我就60岁了。10年前，我40岁。我记得我40岁的时候。感觉几乎没过多久。我余生想在地球上做些什么？有很多我一直在拖延的事情，长长的一串。我现在明确知道的一件事是，生孩子根本不在那份清单上。
Melanie did want children eventually. We'd been together a year since before the pandemic, fell in love fairly quickly. It was the first serious relationship I'd had in a while. Also, during long stretches of 2020, we barely saw anybody else in person. Certainly didn't hug anybody else. Lucky for me, she's insanely funny and caring. Lying in bed one morning, a month after Ed died, I told Melanie what I decided about children. She cried, went home, came back 36 hours later. We sat on the couch. It was civil, tender even. Melanie felt bad. "I don't want to abandon you," she said. "But I need to take care of myself, too." I understood.
梅兰妮最终确实想要孩子。我们在疫情前就在一起一年了，很快就相爱了。这是我很久以来第一次认真的恋爱关系。而且，在2020年的漫长时间里，我们几乎没有亲身见过别人。当然也没拥抱过别人。幸运的是，她非常风趣、有爱心。埃德去世一个月后的一个早晨，躺在床上时，我告诉了梅兰妮我关于孩子的决定。她哭了，回家了，36小时后回来了。我们坐在沙发上。过程很文明，甚至很温柔。梅兰妮感到很难过。“我不想抛弃你，”她说，“但我需要照顾好我自己。”我理解。
I think it was around this time that my sadnesses were already starting to compete with each other, almost cancel each other out. I was aware of not being able to feel the loss of the breakup enough or not proportional enough to the importance of it, like that part of me was already taken up. Then, a few weeks after the breakup, two months after Ed's death, the third thing happened. Melanie sent me a picture of a home pregnancy test. I, at 49 years old, had never seen one, at least not one with the two lines on it, indicating it was positive. Melanie had been taking birth control when we were together. I think she must have missed a day-- one day.
我想就是在这个时候，我的悲伤开始互相竞争，几乎抵消了彼此。我意识到自己无法充分感受到分手的痛苦，或者说与其重要性不成比例，好像我那部分心理空间已经被占满了。然后，在分手几周后，埃德去世两个月后，第三件事发生了。梅兰妮给我发了一张验孕棒的照片。我，49岁了，从来没见过那个东西，至少没见过上面有两条线表示呈阳性的那种。梅兰妮和我在一起时一直在采取避孕措施。我想她一定是漏了一天——就一天。
Now when we were a couple, Melanie was pretty clear that she didn't want a kid right now. But now that she was pregnant, things were different. Melanie was paralyzed with indecision, didn't even know how to decide what to do. I know it sounds self-centered and beside the point to focus on how I felt about it. It goes without saying that my stress was puny compared to hers.
现在，当我们还是情侣时，梅兰妮很清楚她现在不想生孩子。但既然她怀孕了，情况就不同了。梅兰妮被犹豫所瘫痪，甚至不知道该如何决定做什么。我知道关注我的感受听起来很自我中心，也偏离了重点。不用说，我的压力和她的相比简直微不足道。
But midway through that week, pacing around my apartment late at night, I snapped and started weeping. And I wasn't sure why, which one of these upheavals it was about or just all of them. Maybe more than ever, I just wanted to talk to Ed. I had already started to face the fact that I would never be able to go home again. It hadn't hit me yet that I would also never be able to call home again.
但在那一周的中段，深夜我在公寓里踱步时，我崩溃了，开始痛哭。我不确定原因，不知道这源于这些变动中的哪一个，或者是全部。也许我比以往任何时候都更想和埃德谈谈。我已经开始面对我再也回不了家了的事实。我还没有意识到我也再也无法给家里打电话了。
Melanie and I were supposed to get together, the two of us, that Saturday night to discuss what we each were thinking. But we didn't get the chance. Because then the fourth thing happened. That Saturday afternoon, I got a text from my stepmother, my biological dad's wife. "Your father had a heart attack," it said. He was in a hospital in Massachusetts, unconscious. Talking with Melanie about how the rest of our lives were going to pan out would have to wait.
梅兰妮和我原定那个周六晚上在一起，两个人讨论我们各自的想法。但我们没机会了。因为第四件事发生了。那个周六下午，我收到继母——也就是我亲生父亲妻子的短信。“你父亲心脏病发作了，”短信说。他在马萨诸塞州的一家医院里，失去了知觉。和梅兰妮讨论我们余生会如何发展只能推迟了。
For the second time in two months, I had to say goodbye to a parent. My dad-- Mac was his name-- was also 90, had been going downhill with dementia for years. He'd tell you a story, and then 10 minutes later, tell it again, ask the same question over and over again during a short visit. But he never forgot who any of us were, was still able to recite poems and song lyrics he'd learned when he was younger, still charming. He charmed the nurses at the hospital right up until he slipped into unconsciousness in the ICU.
在两个月内第二次，我不得不和父母道别。我的父亲——他的名字叫麦克——也90岁了，患痴呆症已经多年。他会给你讲一个故事，然后10分钟后，又讲一遍，在短时间内反复问同一个问题。但他从没忘记我们是谁，依然能够背诵他在年轻时学过的诗歌和歌词，依然很有魅力。他在医院里一直很迷人，直到他在重症监护室陷入昏迷。
I stood right by his bed for a lot of my visit to the hospital. His wife and three stepkids and a couple of grandkids were there, too. I felt bad for them and for my dad. And-- this is strange-- I knew that I was sad, but it's like I was holding the sadness in my hands, outside my body, because I didn't know where to put it. The thing about cumulative grief, when the losses pile up in quick succession like this, you can get overloaded and end up grieving none of them. Experts on this stuff will tell you that, just like you love everyone in your life differently and separately, you have to grieve them differently and separately when the time comes.
住院期间，我大部分时间都站在他的床边。他的妻子、三个继子女和几个孙辈也在那里。我为他们和我父亲感到难过。而且——这很奇怪——我知道我很伤心，但就像我把悲伤握在手里，放在身体外面一样，因为我不知道该把它放在哪里。关于累积悲伤，当损失像这样接二连三地堆积起来时，你可能会超载，最后对任何一个都无法哀悼。关于这些的专家会告诉你，就像你以不同方式和分别去爱生活中的每个人一样，当时间到来时，你必须以不同方式和分别去哀悼他们。
I love my dad. He and my mom divorced when I was five. Ed entered the picture a year later and eventually moved in with us. And proximity took over, as it does. Standing in the hospital room, one of my stepbrothers said something genuinely funny, and I laughed. And he told me my laugh sounded exactly like dad's. It used to be I didn't like being compared to my father. But now it made me feel closer to him in a way I needed right then. I wanted to stay there all night, like some of the others were going to, but I couldn't. I had to get back to New York to go with Melanie to the OB/GYN the next day to confirm the pregnancy and learn about our options.
我爱我父亲。他和我妈妈在我五岁时离婚了。埃德一年后出现在我们的生活中，最终搬进来和我们住在一起。近距离接触发挥了作用，就像它常做的那样。站在医院的房间里，我其中一个继兄弟说了一些真正有趣的话，我笑了。他告诉我我的笑声听起来和爸爸的一模一样。过去我并不喜欢被拿来和父亲作比较。但现在这让我觉得在那一刻以一种我需要的方式和他更亲近了。我想整晚待在那儿，就像其他人打算做的那样，但我不能。我必须赶回纽约，第二天陪梅兰妮去看妇产科，以确认怀孕情况并了解我们的选择。
It's not lost on me that just as I said goodbye to two fathers, there was a real possibility of becoming one myself. Whether or not someone is equipped to be a parent, it seems like one prerequisite is not being filled with abject terror at the very thought of it. And I'm not the type of person who could tell the mother of his kid that she's on her own.
我意识到，就在我告别两个父亲的同时，我也确实有可能成为一个父亲。无论一个人是否具备做家长的能力，似乎前提条件之一就是对这一想法本身不会感到极度的恐惧。而且我不是那种会告诉孩子母亲她得独自承担这一切的人。
I asked Melanie's permission to talk about all of this on the show, by the way. She said yes, as long as I told her ahead of time what I was going to say and identified her as little as possible. I stayed in the examination room while they did the sonogram, and they said they thought Melanie was about four weeks along. The next morning, I woke up to a text from my stepmother, saying dad had finally died. When my editor at the show and I talked later that day, I said, you're not going to believe this.
顺便说一句，我请求梅兰妮允许我在节目中谈论这一切。她说可以，只要我提前告诉她我要说什么，并尽可能少地暴露她的身份。他们做超声波检查时，我待在检查室里，他们说他们认为梅兰妮大约怀孕四周了。第二天早上，我醒来看到继母发的短信，说爸爸终于去世了。那天晚些时候我和节目的编辑交谈时，我说，你不会相信的。
Melanie ultimately decided to terminate the pregnancy. In the end, she felt clear about it. Even still, she sat on my couch afterwards in tears. Said she could feel that it wasn't in there anymore somehow. She called it a dead thing. Any nascent relief in me was swallowed up by sadness and concern. This was the outcome I'd hoped for, but it's not like it felt good. And it never would. It was its own kind of loss.
梅兰妮最终决定终止妊娠。最后，她觉得很清楚。尽管如此，事后她还是坐在我的沙发上流泪。她说她能感觉到它不知怎么地不在里面了。她称它为死物。我内心任何微弱的解脱都被悲伤和担忧所吞噬。这是我希望的结果，但并不意味着这感觉很好。而且它永远也不会。这是它自己的一种损失。
It's been five months now since I held Ed's lifeless body in my arms. I'm still distracting myself from my grief too much, I think, with work and also drinking, partying with friends now that we're all vaccinated. The difference now, as opposed to five years ago when mom died, is that I know I'm avoiding grief. And it feels like I turn and kind of glance at it multiple times a day, sometimes longer glances than others. I still don't know exactly how I'm supposed to proceed, how to pull all of the different losses apart in order to grieve them separately or in what order. Do I do it sequentially? Do I have to finish with one before starting on the next one?
我把埃德毫无生气的身体抱在怀里已经五个月了。我认为我仍然通过工作和喝酒来过多地转移悲伤，现在大家都接种了疫苗，开始和朋友聚会。现在的不同之处在于，与五年前妈妈去世时相比，我知道自己在回避悲伤。感觉我每天会转头看它好几次，有时 glances 时间更长一些。我仍然不知道我到底应该如何继续，如何把所有不同的损失分开以分别哀悼，或者按什么顺序。我应该按顺序进行吗？我必须在开始下一个之前完成前一个吗？
There's one other big thought I had. Not in the wake of dad's death or Ed's death, but back when my mom died. I'd forgotten about it until all this happened. I was asking myself why we were all even here, what it was all for. I don't have any faith or doctrine. I'm not even secure enough in my understanding of the cosmos to be an atheist.
我有另一个重大的想法。不是在爸爸去世或埃德去世后，而是在我妈妈去世时。直到所有这些发生，我才想起它。我当时问自己我们为什么还要在这里，这一切是为了什么。我没有任何信仰或教义。我对宇宙的理解甚至不够稳固到成为一个无神论者。
But I did come up with an answer. It's simple, and it makes even more sense to me now when I think of how Maggie and I looked out for each other when caring for Ed got really stressful, or Melanie and I being present through even the hardest conversations, or the folks at dad's hospital bending the COVID rules, letting us all crowd around his bed for hours. The reason we're all here, I think, is to get each other to the other side.
但我确实想出了一个答案。这很简单，当我想到玛吉和我在埃德的护理变得非常紧张时是如何互相关照，或者梅兰妮和我在即便最艰难的对话中如何保持在场，又或者爸爸医院里的人打破新冠规则，让我们所有人围在他的床边几个小时时，这答案对我来说就更有意义了。我想，我们所有人之所以在这里，是为了带彼此到达另一边。
Sean Cole is a producer here at our show. Coming up, saying goodbye to yourself. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制片人。接下来，向你自己道别。节目将在一分钟后从芝加哥公共广播电台继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Good Grief. You know it is hard to talk about death. It's hard to know how to face it. It's hard to know how to grieve. Today, for this Memorial Day weekend, we have people figuring out for themselves, inventing for themselves how to deal with loss. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, The Caretaker.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《好的悲伤》。你知道谈论死亡很难。知道如何面对它很难。知道如何哀悼很难。今天，在这个阵亡将士纪念日周末，我们有人们自己在弄清楚、在为自己发明如何面对损失。我们已经进入节目的第三幕。第三幕，看护者。
So there are memorial sites that are planned out over years by official committees and designers and architects. But sometimes, something happens that leads to such an outpouring of grief, such an overflow of emotion, that a site to mourn and commemorate just springs into existence spontaneously. Hundreds of individuals show up, lots of them with photos and signs and other stuff. The intersection of 38th Street and Chicago Avenue in Minneapolis is like that. It's the place where George Floyd was murdered by police officer Derek Chauvin last May. One of our producers, Bim Adewunmi, went to see what it's like.
所以，有一些纪念场所是由官方委员会、设计师和建筑师规划多年的。但有时，发生了一些事情导致了如此巨大的悲伤倾泻，如此强烈的情绪流露，以至于一个哀悼和纪念的场所自发地出现了。数百名个人出现，带着照片、标语牌和其他东西。明尼阿波利斯第38街和芝加哥大道的交叉路口就是这样。那是乔治·弗洛伊德被警察德里克·肖文谋杀的地方，去年五月。我们的一位制片人比姆·阿德温米去看了一下那是种什么样子。
This used to be a busy intersection, but now it's almost entirely vehicle-free, a block in every direction closed to traffic. Cup Foods, the convenience store on the corner, is still going. But other businesses, like the Speedway gas station, have been transformed. The whole space has been reclaimed, and none of it's sanctioned by the city or state. That independence is most notable at the Speedway gas station. The sign has been painted over. It now reads "People's Way."
这里过去是一个繁忙的十字路口，但现在几乎完全没有车辆，每个方向的一个街区都对交通关闭了。角落里的便利店Cup Foods还在营业。但其他企业，比如Speedway加油站，已经发生了转变。整个空间被收回了，而且这一切都没有得到城市或州的批准。这种独立性在Speedway加油站最为显著。标志已经被漆盖过了。现在写着“人民之路”。
George Floyd Square isn't even really a square. It's a wellspring, an organic creation in the aftermath of a traumatic event. As you walk up, right in the middle of the intersection, you see a giant metal sculpture of a fist jutting into the sky, a black liberation flag billowing in the breeze on top of it. All around the sculpture is a ring of bricks and cinder blocks. And it holds hundreds of tributes-- flowers, protest signs, handwritten quotes, plus several photos of George Floyd and other Black men killed elsewhere by police brutality or otherwise-- Ahmaud Arbery, Daunte Wright.
乔治·弗洛伊德广场甚至不是一个真正的广场。它是一个泉源，一个创伤事件后果中有机产生的创造。当你走近时，就在十字路口的中心，你会看到一个巨大的拳头金属雕塑刺向天空，一面黑人解放旗在顶端风中飘扬。雕塑周围是一圈砖块和煤渣砖。它承载着数百个致敬——鲜花、抗议标语、手写的引语，还有几张乔治·弗洛伊德和其他在其他地方被警察暴力或以其他方式杀害的黑人照片——阿玛德·阿伯里、道特·莱特。
On the ground in front of the convenience store is a drawing of an angel, close to where George Floyd took his last breaths. The feeling at George Floyd Square is sacred for sure, but it's a group project, in which the levels of artistic skill are not uniform. There's an air of it being homemade, made with care, by hand, grief mostly from the community and mostly by the community. The people who come here are drawn to that. They have to come. They have to see. They have to feel.
便利店前方的地面上是一个天使的画像，靠近乔治·弗洛伊德呼吸最后一口气的地方。乔治·弗洛伊德广场的感觉无疑是神圣的，但它是一个集体项目，艺术技巧水平参差不齐。有一种手工制作的氛围，带着关怀，亲手制作，悲伤主要来自社区，也主要由社区完成。来到这里的人被这一点吸引。他们必须来。他们必须看。他们必须感受。
One of the people drawn to the square is Jeanelle Austin. She's now treasurer and secretary of the George Floyd Global Memorial, which is co-chaired by George Floyd's aunt and cousin. When George Floyd was murdered, Jeanelle was living in Austin, Texas, doing racial justice work in an organization she'd started. Her family had been asking her to come home for a while, but she'd resisted. Now they asked again, telling her that she should be here for this moment.
被这个广场吸引的人之一是珍妮尔·奥斯汀。她现在是乔治·弗洛伊德全球纪念碑的财务主管和秘书，该纪念碑由乔治·弗洛伊德的姑姑和堂兄共同担任主席。当乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀时，珍妮尔住在德克萨斯州的奥斯汀，在她创立的一个组织中从事种族正义工作。她的家人一直要求她回家，但她一直拒绝。现在他们又问了，告诉她在这个时刻她应该在这里。
Four days after George Floyd's death, Jeanelle flew back to Minneapolis. She started attending protests. At one protest on the highway, she and her sister had a terrifying encounter with a truck that charged up protesters. Afterwards, her sister was crying, but Jeanelle, a seasoned protester, couldn't even muster tears. She made a decision.
乔治·弗洛伊德去世四天后，珍妮尔飞回了明尼阿波利斯。她开始参加抗议活动。在高速公路上的一次抗议中，她和她姐姐遭遇了一辆冲向抗议者的卡车的可怕经历。事后，她姐姐在哭，但作为一名经验丰富的抗议者，珍妮尔甚至连眼泪都挤不出来。她做出了一个决定。
The next morning, I said, yep, we're not going to do that. I was like, I'm just going to do something more simple, but still profound, by keeping the memorial clean. And so I started waking up at 6:00 AM, June 1st, and started tending to the memorial. And I decided that that would be my protest.
第二天早上，我说，是的，我们不那样做了。我说，我只是要去做一些更简单但依然深刻的事情，就是保持纪念碑的整洁。所以从6月1日早上6点开始，我开始起床照料纪念碑。我决定那就是我的抗议。
As more and more people came to the square, they were also bringing the things Jeanelle calls offerings-- protest signs, drawings, photos of their loved ones killed by police, small tokens like teddy bears and candles, and an overwhelming amount of flowers and potted plants. She spent several hours a day at the square some days, usually with her neighbor Paul, caretaking as best she could. In those early days, she reckoned on the whole thing winding down after about a fortnight.
随着越来越多的人来到广场，他们也带来了珍妮尔所说的供品——抗议标语、图画、他们被警察杀害的亲人的照片、小纪念品如泰迪熊和蜡烛，以及数量惊人的鲜花和盆栽植物。有些日子她在广场上花了好几个小时，通常和她的邻居保罗在一起，尽其所能地看护。在最初的那些天里，她预计整个事情在大约两周后就会平息。
At the end of two weeks, we were like, nope, still going. And so we kind of had the conversation of, what do we do with all the offerings? And so, it was so funny. He said, well, in many traditions, with offerings, we burn them, and they go up into the sky. And I'm like, Paul, the city's on fire. We're not burning offerings. That is a bad idea.
两周结束时，我们想，不，还在持续。于是我们就讨论，我们该怎么处理所有的供品？这真的很好笑。他说，嗯，在许多传统中，对于供品，我们烧掉它们，然后它们就升入天空了。我当时说，保罗，城市在着火。我们不能烧供品。那是个坏主意。
Right, you don't want to be the people who burn stuff.
对，你不想成为那些烧东西的人。
Right, right, exactly. He was like, you're right.
对，对，确实。他说，你是对的。
Jeanelle has watched the square evolve over the past year. On the day she's there, she's cleaning up trash or pruning the plants people bring to the square in the hastily constructed greenhouse. The nature of the work suits her. She's an introvert and finds peace in tending to the offerings.
珍妮尔在过去一年里看着广场演变。在她在那里的日子里，她清理垃圾或修剪人们带到急忙搭建的温室里的植物。工作的性质很适合她。她是个内向的人，在照顾这些供品中找到了平静。
On the day I visited, there were a few families walking around and reading the names and signs in contemplative silence. I spoke to people from Minneapolis-- a father and his partner and their two little ones, another guy who would come to the square with his teenage daughter, fresh from a dance recital. There were men who'd come from California and Texas, one Nigerian guy who'd come from Georgia to see friends and felt compelled to visit the memorial. They all came to grieve for a man they'd never know, but felt familiar to them. A man who had gone out to get cigarettes and had never made it back home.
我去参观的那天，有几个家庭在广场走动，在沉思的寂静中阅读那些名字和标语。我与来自明尼阿波利斯的人交谈——一位父亲和他的伴侣以及他们的两个小孩，另一个带十几岁女儿来广场的人，刚从舞蹈演出回来。还有来自加利福尼亚和德克萨斯的人，一位从佐治亚州来见朋友的尼日利亚人，他觉得必须访问这个纪念碑。他们都是来为一个他们从未认识但感觉很熟悉的男人哀悼。一个出门去买烟却再也没能回家的人。
I saw people grieving. And I saw that because I was there, many of them would just tap me on my shoulder and say, hey, can I talk? Or one person pulled up a whole lawn chair and was like, I am going to hold you hostage because you're there cutting plants, and I need somebody to talk to. Or some people just would come and just stand by me and say nothing. But because I was there, they just needed to be. And I recognized it as grief. Because I've been journeying through grief myself.
我看到人们在哀悼。我看到是因为我在那里，他们中的许多人会拍拍我的肩膀说，嘿，我能谈谈吗？或者有人搬来一把折叠椅，就像，因为你在那里修剪植物，我要把你扣为人质，我需要有人和我说话。或者有些人过来只是站在我旁边，什么都不说。但因为我在那里，他们只是需要那种状态。我认识到这是悲伤。因为我也一直在经历悲伤。
Everybody processes loss differently. And I learned that a year earlier, when my father had died from cancer. And I have six brothers and sisters, and we all processed my dad's death differently. So for some people, processing loss meant being angry. For some people, processing loss meant creating art. For some people, processing loss meant being quiet and staying home. And I think that was one of the things that actually prepared me for this moment.
每个人处理损失的方式都不同。我一年前在我父亲死于癌症时学到了这一点。我有六个兄弟姐妹，我们处理父亲去世的方式都各不相同。所以对有些人来说，处理损失意味着愤怒。对有些人来说，处理损失意味着创作艺术。对有些人来说，处理损失意味着保持安静，呆在家里。我想这实际上是让我为这一刻做好准备的事情之一。
I'll never forget this white man, middle-aged white man, was in the square early in the morning. And I was in the square, carrying a five-gallon bucket of water to water the plants. And he said, "Can I help you?" And I said, "Absolutely." And so, we started chit chatting. And he was like, "Did you know that every gallon of water weighs eight pounds?" I'm like, "No, I didn't know that." And so we got to the memorial. We had to walk a half a block up. And he just looked sad.
我永远不会忘记这个白人，中年白人，在清晨来到广场。当时我在广场，提着一个五加仑的水桶去给植物浇水。他说，“我能帮你吗？”我说，“当然。”于是我们开始闲聊。他说，“你知道每加仑水重八磅吗？”我说，“不，我不知道。”于是我们到了纪念碑。我们必须往前走半个街区。他看起来很伤心。
And I look at him, and I say, "Whatever it is that you're holding, the space is big enough. You can let it go. The space is big enough for it all." And he just starts to cry. And he says, "My son is under a knife. And my mother died in January." And that's when I notice his visitor badge, the hospital. And he was like, "But none of that compares to what we're dealing with here." And I said, "No, no, no, you don't get to do that. Grief is grief. Loss is loss. It's not about comparing losses. Your loss is your loss. And we can hold that, too."
我看着他说，“无论你抱着什么，这个空间足够大。你可以把它放下。这个空间大到足以容纳这一切。”他开始哭泣。他说，“我的儿子正在接受手术。我母亲一月份去世了。”就在这时，我注意到了他的访客胸牌，是医院的。他说，“但这都比不上我们在这里处理的事情。”我说，“不，不，不，你不能那样做。悲伤就是悲伤。损失就是损失。这不是在比较损失。你的损失就是你的损失。我们可以承接那个。”
The point of a place like George Floyd Square is that it is many things to many people, all at the same time. Grief is vast. And it is strong, which means it can carry a lot inside it. The names of the dead at the square-- and there are dozens of them-- are everywhere.
乔治·弗洛伊德广场这样的地方的意义在于，它对许多人来说是许多事物的集合，同时发生。悲伤是广阔的。而且它是强大的，这意味着它可以承载很多东西在里面。广场上死者的名字——有几十个——无处不在。
They're scrawled on the road, stenciled or drawn freehand in chalk and paint. They're on planters, on walls, on signs staked into the ground, on rocks, on T-shirts and on hats. Many of the names are familiar, like the names of your cousins on your father's side. Others require you to dig deeper into the past or further than the first page of a Google search. The square lets people bring other older griefs and lay them down as part of a continuum of what's been lost to a persistent problem.
它们被乱涂在马路上，用粉笔和油漆镂空或手绘。它们在花盆上、墙上、插在地里的牌子上、岩石上、T恤上和帽子上。许多名字很熟悉，就像你父亲那边的堂兄弟的名字。其他的则需要你深入挖掘过去，或者比谷歌搜索的第一页挖掘得更深。广场让人们带入其他旧有的悲伤，并将它们作为一种持续损失的连续体的一部分放下。
I want to circle to that idea of grief and protest. Because the two things don't seem like they necessarily go hand in hand.
我想回到那个悲伤和抗议的概念。因为这两件事看起来并不必然齐头并进。
I think the protest was burst out of grief. The DNA of the protest is grief. And I don't even think I fully understood that until recently and looking back and realizing that what made this protest different was the fact that that grief was the foundation, and not rage. I mean, there was anger and there was rage there, yeah, but it really was grief. It's the grief and the protests are wrapped into one another and marbled together. I don't think you could separate the two.
我认为抗议是源于悲伤。抗议的DNA就是悲伤。直到最近回头看，意识到这场抗议与众不同的事实是悲伤作为基础，而不是愤怒，我才真正明白这一点。我的意思是，确实有愤怒和暴怒在，是的，但那确实是悲伤。悲伤和抗议交织在一起，结合在一起。我不认为你能把两者分开。
The anniversary of George Floyd's death this past week transformed the square into something else again. It hosted an outdoor festival of remembrance for the community, the culmination of protests in the city-- music, panels, talks. We don't usually think of those as expressions of grief, but they are. Because grief doesn't end. It just changes form.
刚过去的这一周乔治·弗洛伊德去世一周年纪念日，再次将广场转变成了另一种存在。它为社区举办了露天纪念活动，是城市中抗议活动的高潮——音乐、小组讨论、演讲。我们通常不认为这些是悲伤的表达，但它们确实是。因为悲伤不会结束。它只是改变了形式。
Bim Adewunmi is one of the producers of our show.
比姆·阿德温米是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Four, All My Love. OK, so nearly 600,000 people dead from COVID. It is really hard to get your mind around that number, what that means, what that is. I went and looked this up. That is, more or less, the population of Milwaukee or Portland or Albuquerque or Louisville or Nashville or Las Vegas or Baltimore, which is where I grew up.
第四幕，全部的爱。好吧，接近60万人死于新冠。要理解那个数字，这意味着什么，那是什么，真的很困难。我特地去查了查。这或多或少是密尔沃基、波特兰、阿尔伯克基、路易斯维尔、纳什维尔、拉斯维加斯或者是巴尔的摩的人口，那是我长大的地方。
And I try to picture the whole city of Baltimore, OK? All the streets and row houses and strip malls and grocery stores and high schools and parks just completely empty of people. The rundown blocks around Lexington Market downtown and the pretty green area up by Johns Hopkins University, just block after block, mile after mile, nobody there at all. And then I kind of get it, but only kind of. It's just easier to feel the loss of one person than some big number. I think everybody knows that.
我试着去想象整个巴尔的摩市，好吗？所有的街道、连排房屋、购物广场、杂货店、高中和公园完全空无一人。市中心列克星敦市场周围破旧的街区，以及约翰霍普金斯大学附近美丽的绿地，街区接街区，英里接英里，一个人都没有。然后我有点明白了，但只是有点。感受一个人的损失比一个巨大的数字更容易。我想每个人都知道这一点。
One of those 590,000-plus Americans who's died was Leiah Danielle Jones. She is one of the people who got COVID and never fully recovered and became one of the long haulers, and then she died on March 12. And before she died, she wrote her own obituary. And we got permission from her brother to read it here on the radio. He says, the truth is, they aren't totally sure why she wrote this. He assumes it was for the family. But as you'll hear, she also addresses a larger audience. The family decided to use it for the funeral. And it was posted online as an obituary. We asked actress Pernell Walker to read it.
在那超过59万名死去的美国人中，有一位是蕾雅·丹妮尔·琼斯。她是那些感染新冠后从未完全康复，成为长期后遗症患者之一的人，然后她在3月12日去世了。在她去世前，她写了自己的讣告。我们从她兄弟那里获得了在电台上朗读的许可。他说，事实是，他们不完全确定她为什么写这个。他假设这是为了家人。但正如你将听到的，她也向更广大的观众讲话。家人决定在葬礼上使用它。它被作为讣告发布在网上。我们邀请演员珀内尔·沃克朗读。
I, Leiah Danielle Jones, was born on September 22, 1987 in Charlotte, North Carolina to Eric Arnelle Jones and Joyce Bost Jones. Waiting patiently at home was my elder and only brother, Jonathan Philemon Jones. I departed from my temporary home on March 12, 2021, surrounded by my family. I am waiting for Christ's return. I was 33 and 1/2 years young.
我，蕾雅·丹妮尔·琼斯，出生于1987年9月22日，北卡罗来纳州夏洛特，父母是埃里克·阿内尔·琼斯和乔伊斯·博斯特·琼斯。耐心等待在家的是我唯一的哥哥，乔纳森·菲勒蒙·琼斯。我于2021年3月12日离开了我的临时家园，家人环绕在身边。我正在等待基督的归来。我当时33岁半，年轻。
I died due to complications from COVID-19, which none of us knew existed 1 and 1/2 years ago. I, along with others like me, are termed long-haulers. The term "long-hauler" means a person who has been infected by the virus and has recovered, no longer infectious. However, the damage had been done to vital organs. A YouTube video on this site will inform you more explicitly the extent of this virus. Unfortunately, those like me may or may not survive the aftermath. I, hopefully, am in the minority of those numbers. I would love for as many as can to watch the video and please pray and support the long-haulers.
我死于新冠-19的并发症，这是我们1年半前都不知道存在的东西。我和其他像我一样的人被称为长期后遗症患者。“长期后遗症患者”一词是指感染了病毒且已经康复，不再具有传染性的人。然而，重要器官已经受到了损害。本网站上的一个YouTube视频将更明确地告知你这种病毒的程度。不幸的是，像我这样的人可能幸存，也可能不会。希望我属于这部分少数数字。我希望尽可能多的人能观看该视频，并请祈祷和支持长期后遗症患者。
What can I say, but to God be the glory. Great things He has done, even in my short life. He gave me qualities of compassion, generosity, boundless energy, knowledge, and determination, a.k.a. stubbornness, which my mom would say of me. If you met me, you would have never forgotten that Jones girl. I loved to cook-- Dad's gift to me. I had many specialties. Breadmaking was just one.
我还能说什么，只能荣耀归于上帝。他做出了伟大的事，即便是在我短暂的一生中。他给了我同情心、慷慨、无限的精力、知识和决心，也就是我妈妈所说的“顽固”。如果你见过我，你就永远不会忘记那个琼斯家的女孩。我热爱烹饪——那是爸爸给我的礼物。我有很多拿手菜。做面包只是其中之一。
In my own way, I championed many causes-- namely, A, people who are considered the undesirables, outcasts of society; B, support to families, especially the single home parent; C, children, those who were affected by the school closings due to the pandemic; D, victims of the hurricanes, wildfires, national and international.
我以自己的方式倡导了许多事业——即，A，被社会视为不受欢迎、被排斥的人；B，对家庭的支持，尤其是单亲家庭；C，儿童，那些因疫情导致的学校关闭而受到影响的孩子；D，飓风、野火的受害者，国内和国际的。
My mom would accuse me of disaster hunting, seeing all the good others were doing and saving lives-- Mercy Ships, St. Jude Children's Research, Feed the Children campaign. It didn't take much. Oh, by the way, let's not forget the poor abused animals. The gift that God entrusted with me was amazing-- nursing baby kittens, helping injured ones. It amazed even me. And I always knew it was a special gift from Him.
我妈妈会指责我是在进行灾难搜寻，看着别人所做的所有好事并挽救生命——怜悯之船、圣裘德儿童研究、喂养儿童运动。这并不需要多少。哦，顺便说一句，别忘了那些可怜被虐待的动物。上帝托付给我的天赋太惊人了——护理小猫，帮助受伤的猫。这甚至让我自己都感到惊讶。我总是知道这是他给我的特殊天赋。
The most rewarding part of my life was the day I was able to take care of my mom. She had been badly injured in a lawnmower accident. Being unable to properly care for herself for months, love stepped in. Of course, she protested-- stubborn woman.
我生命中最有意义的部分是我能照顾我妈妈的那一天。她在割草机事故中受了重伤。几个月来无法妥善照顾自己，爱介入了。当然，她反抗了——顽固的女人。
As my health declined and my illness progressed, I became physically hampered somewhat from doing my regular daily routine. Therefore, I leaned more heavily on the help of my mom. She, on the most part, was more than willing. The few times she was not so willing, I, Leiah Danielle Jones, prevailed. I pressed on with the affairs of home and business. Yes, Dad dragged me in on this EA Jones plumbing adventure. Life and its pull were getting the best of me by the end of last year. However, God and my family powered the best in and for me till the end.
随着我的健康状况下滑和疾病进展，我在进行日常例行事务方面在某种程度上受到了身体上的阻碍。因此，我更多地依赖了妈妈的帮助。她大部分时间都很乐意。那几次她不那么乐意的时候，我，蕾雅·丹妮尔·琼斯，还是占据了上风。我继续处理家庭和商业事务。是的，爸爸把我拉进了这次EA琼斯管道探险中。去年年底，生活及其压力让我陷入了困境。然而，上帝和我的家人在最后时刻给予了我最好的力量和支持。
If, in this life, we met, I hope our encounter left you with a lasting snapshot of a determined, sometimes complex, genuine friend, one you could talk to. If, however, we did not meet, it was my loss, and I am sorry. I believe that every person, experience, good or bad, added to my life a measure of maturity.
如果，在这一生中我们见过面，我希望我们的相遇给你留下了关于一个坚决、有时复杂、真诚朋友的持久快照，一个你可以交谈的人。然而，如果我们没见过，那是我的损失，我很抱歉。我相信每一个人、每一次经历，无论好坏，都让我的人生增加了成熟度。
Lastly, in my own defense of my very interesting family-- to you, Dad, Eric Arnell Jones, you were my daddy, with all your strengths and weaknesses. I wouldn't have traded you for the world or for another earthly father. I loved you. To you, Mom, Joyce Ann Bost Jones, we would refer to you as Brick because of your non-compromising positions, but only when you did not agree with us. But as for your love for us, it never wavered, like a rock. Brick, I loved you.
最后，为我这非常有趣的家人辩护——给你，爸爸，埃里克·阿内尔·琼斯，你是我的爸爸，有着所有的优点和弱点。我不会用全世界或另一个地上的父亲来换取你。我爱你。给你，妈妈，乔伊斯·安·博斯特·琼斯，我们因为你不妥协的立场称你为“砖块”，但这只是当你不同意我们的时候。但至于你对我们的爱，它从未动摇，就像一块岩石。砖块，我爱你。
To my dearest brother, Jonathan Philemon Jones, we had our battles as siblings do. But when it matters, we, love, showed up. When you needed me, I came through. And when I needed you, Jonathan, you showed up big time. At the end, I needed you. And you said yes. Thank you. And I loved you. Don't you ever, ever forget that.
给我最亲爱的哥哥，乔纳森·菲勒蒙·琼斯，我们像兄妹一样经历过争吵。但当重要的时候，我们，爱，出现了。你需要我时，我挺身而出。而我需要你时，乔纳森，你非常及时地出现了。最后，我需要你。而你答应了。谢谢你。我爱你。不要忘记，永远都不要忘记这一点。
To the rest of my family-- uncles, aunts, cousins-- and friends, I hope my life has left you with an enduring and lasting picture frame of someone who lived life her way. I loved you. May the grace of God and His marvelous love and in His power sustain you forever. With all my love, Leiah.
给我的其他家人——叔叔、阿姨、堂兄弟姐妹——和朋友，我希望我的一生给你们留下了一张关于一个以自己的方式生活的人的持久肖像画。我爱你们。愿上帝的恩典、他美妙的爱和他的力量永远支撑你们。带着我所有的爱，蕾雅。
The words of Leiah Danielle Jones, who died March 12, read by actress Pernell Walker.
蕾雅·丹妮尔·琼斯的话，她于3月12日去世，由演员珀内尔·沃克朗读。
[MUSIC - "THE OTHER SIDE" BY JUDITH HILL]
（音乐 - 朱迪斯·希尔的《另一边》）
Well, our program was produced today by Elna Baker and Sean Cole. The people who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Aviva DeKornfeld, Damien Graef, Chana Joffe-Walt, Rudy Lee, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ari Saperstein, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
那么，我们今天的节目由埃尔娜·贝克和肖恩·科尔制作。负责今天节目的人员包括比姆·阿德温米、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、达米安·格拉夫、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、鲁迪·李、赛斯·林德、托宾·洛、米基·米克、莉娜·米西齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、阿里·萨珀斯坦、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的主编是萨拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。
Special thanks today to Amy Potter, Dale Larson, Amy Tucci, Katherine Supiano, Bonnie Carroll, Ken Doka, Katherine Shear, Karen Goldman, Carolyn Taverner, Catherine Toronto, Robert Neimeyer, Pauline Dyer Grey Cole, Maggie Cole, Brian and Peg Walter, and COVID Survivors for Change. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's lists of favorite shows that we recommend for long car rides, tons of other stuff there, too. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
今天特别感谢艾米·波特、戴尔·拉尔森、艾米·图奇、凯瑟琳·苏皮亚诺、邦妮·卡罗尔、肯·多卡、凯瑟琳·希尔、凯伦·戈德曼、卡罗琳·塔弗纳、凯瑟琳·多伦多、罗伯特·内梅耶、保琳·戴尔·格雷·科尔、玛吉·科尔、布莱恩和佩格·沃尔特，以及“新冠幸存者改变计划”。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。你可以完全免费收听我们超过700集的档案。此外，还有视频。有我们推荐用于长途车旅行的最爱节目列表，上面还有很多其他东西。再次，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He's actually picked up a second job to make a little extra money. He's selling women's shoes out of the back of an SUV, saying things like--
《美国生活》通过PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他实际上找了一份第二职业来多挣点零花钱。他正在从SUV的后备箱里卖女鞋，说着类似这样的话——
What we have on this truck is going to be pumps.
这辆卡车上装的是泵。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "THE OTHER SIDE" BY JUDITH HILL]
（音乐 - 朱迪斯·希尔的《另一边》）